so there's just one more aspect of
yesterday's completely clown car
humiliating Twitter hearings that
Republicans orchestrated now that they
control the House of Representatives
that I want to look at separately and it
is about the snowflake triggered nature
of the failed former president Donald
Trump who tried to get a tweet from
celebrity Chrissy Teigen about him
removed from Twitter now there is some
strong language in this segment I'm
giving you fair warning even before I
get to it I'm just letting you know that
there is strong language in this segment
um one of the stories that has been told
by the right is that the Biden
Administration which of course was not
an administration at the time it was it
was a campaign
was demanding content be removed from
Twitter
simply because it was disadvantageous to
Joe Biden now when you evaluate that
claim what you find out is that the
Biden Administration wanted explicit
images of Hunter Biden shared without
his consent against Twitter terms of
service and a crime in Most states
removed and that was absolutely
legitimate but we have now found out
that there was a TR a tweet which just
was insulting to Trump that he wanted
removed here is a congressman Frost
speaking to Twitter Executives about
this again there is strong language here
listen to what it was that Trump wanted
removed from Twitter
yeah Miss uh uh niravoli earlier you
testified about a 2019 tweet
um that was about President Trump and I
think it's from uh Miss Teigen what was
the Tweet about
would you like me to give the direct
quote yeah
um please excuse my language this is a
direct quote but Chrissy Teigen referred
to Donald Trump as a ass
okay
free speech and what happened after Miss
Teegan posted her tweet what did the
White House do what did the Trump White
House do for my understanding the White
House reached out to ask that this tweet
be removed now folks that's not a
campaign that's an Administration that
is government
calling Twitter emailing Twitter sending
a smoke signal to Twitter and saying
remove the speech of this private
citizen on a private platform it was my
team's job this fell underneath the
policy for abusive behaviors and we
evaluate it underneath our insults
policy at that time up to three insults
were allowed and so it was our job to
determine how many insults were included
within that phrase right right White
House reached out not an agency but the
White House reached out and request that
you remove the the tweet from my
understanding yes yeah
that is the epitome of these right
Wingers the left wants everything
censored well they want images that are
a crime censored but you want Chrissy
Teigen censored because she called you
names and the irony is that Trump's
attempt to censor the Tweet
reinforces the accuracy of Chrissy
teigen's tweet that's the the amazing
thing they say Twitter censoring
conservatives while they are demanding
that liberals be censored for opinions
that are of no National Security
implication they're not doxing anybody
nobody's at risk nobody's in danger
Trump has the best protection ever even
if someone saw Chrissy teigen's tweet
and they wanted to go and do something
to trump it is the uh uh theme of
authoritarian narcissists being very
thin-skinned people like Trump and we
can look in history and find other
examples they see
statements they see criticism like this
as a threat to their power and their ego
Hitler Stalin Kim Jong-un just to name a
few they all had the same uh personality
trait Hitler as the leader of Germany
was Infamous for his sensitivity to
criticism and he saw media as a tool for
propaganda he would suppress criticism
of his regime he would censor newspapers
he would jail journalists because these
authoritarian narcissists see themselves
as threatened by any kind of criticism
another example Joseph Stalin former
leader of the Soviet Union Stalin would
brutally repress dissent he would
imprison and sometimes execute critics
and political opponents he saw criticism
as a direct threat to his Rule and he
did everything he could to silence it
and then more recently in North Korea
Kim Jong-un um and and there's more it
goes earlier than just Kim Jong-un Kim
Jong-il and others but an authoritarian
leader who is so thin-skinned Kim
Jong-un notorious for strictly
controlling information suppressing
descent and Doling out severe punishment
for criticism of the regime Trump is not
Hitler Stalin or Kim Jong-un
but Trump has that same authoritarian
narcissistic tendency that they do and
it's embarrassing and it's pathetic and
again
allegations are confessions the left is
trying to censor our speech they're not
but you're trying to censor the left
speech that's what we keep learning
here's the perfect last minute
Valentine's Day gift one of our sponsors
paired is the app that offers you daily
questions games and guided conversations
for couples designed by clinical
psychologists an independent study by
open University found couples who use
paired for three months see an average
36 percent increase in the quality of
their relationship every day paird sends
you and your partner prompts designed to
let you emotionally connect in a
meaningful way you don't see their
answer until you've answered and using
paired just a few minutes a day lets you
build a deeper knowledge of yourself and
your partner boost intimacy there are
hilarious moments as well my girlfriend
and I have been using it and it is
really funny and interesting so this
Valentine's Day give a gift that will
last beyond the holiday go to paired.com
Pacman get a seven day free trial and 25
off a subscription even the free trial
makes an awesome gift see if you like it
the link is down below